order
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another edition of old vs.
innit
it's the fairy tale that teaches kids
all around the world that doesn't matter
what you look like or where you come
from as long as you work hard and have a
kind heart you too can get a makeover
Cinderella is a tale that's been told
countless times but the most definitive
version belonged to Disney Animation in
1950 so it only figured when you have a
moneymaker so iconic that cemented in
everybody's memory here we make it 65
years later too much surprise though not
only were there big names and astounding
visuals but it also got quite the
critical backing to with people praising
it for being such a stylized update but
as always which one is better which one
feels the most engaging clever and
all-around magical now of course being a
big nostalgic persuasion I have a little
bit of a leaning towards the old
if only I could wish for someone that
had an opposite opinion of me if only I
could wish for someone that had an
opposite opinion of me if only I could
where the hell are you sorry this thing
is really hard to walk in Christ even
what I want to do in a video you can't
get it right hey give me a chance I have
whimsical support on this one yeah who
Grable pizza cool support can you offer
I act again touch my feminine side
what stuck out my ass ahsha oh okay no
it's funny not smashing but on ponies
oh you too still a thing what can I say
I love a woman I write fanfiction about
me oh and we both held your hostage that
one time so we have that in common
give it up better yeah you did yeah
you're good yeah I'm hyper isn't bendy
gonna feel weird that you have another
outlet for mindless violence oh come on
he's a professional assassin this kind
of thing doesn't bother people like him
it's nothing Benny nothing
just add her to the list
okay are you gonna debate me on these
Cinderella movies or not there is no
debate the new one is better if for no
other reason than the lead actors had to
lose two ribs to fit into that dress but
it's so sexist and blam the original is
sexist and bland you just like because
there's more flashy sparkles to play
your inner five-year-old you're a flaky
flailing flashy Hawick what did you call
her honey honey I'm gonna do the
crossover why don't you go start a war
with a random country oh I get to use my
random war generator
jump my cat is so hyper are you ready to
be proven wrong once again the day you
start being right let's do Cinderella
old versus new
sometimes a prince leaves no impact on
you whatsoever dude too soon I was
talking about the Royal position and I'm
not
he's the arm candy of our main
characters dream let's take a look at
best Prince
well a lot of people give flack to some
Disney Princesses for not having enough
character people forget the princes
often weren't even given time to have
character Snow White Sleeping Beauty and
yes
Cinderella all have princes with only a
handful of lines and we're the one from
Sleeping Beauty fought a dragon and the
one from Snow White saved her from death
this one yawns okay look it was a
different time a time when yawning was
an attractive trait I don't think you're
taking to account how sexy that yawn was
his father gets more screen time than
this so does his servant for that matter
yes yes but through them we're
discovering the princess character and
they are also relaying the chemistry
between our two romantic leads you got
nothing I got nothing
now with the remake not only is the
Prince given a lot more on-screen time
but there's also a lot more time to
develop their chemistry Cinderella and
him meet before the ball and they have
time to talk like normal people and
build an appreciation of each other even
during the ball they talk and share
experiences that help them build a
stronger connection she doesn't just see
him and declare this is love like in the
original I wouldn't know anybody who did
that I've moved on critic I found a more
sensible love hey paint it cuz that's
easy - star war with this place you just
tell them that Cool Runnings is a 100%
true story bring me back the Rasta hat
Smoochum weld oh okay so maybe this
prince has more charm more personality
more screentime more chemistry and
pretty much more of a connection with
everybody he comes in contact with but
there is one thing that Prince does not
have a shit ton of eyeliner dude again
too soon just take the point after you
give him an apology he's waiting
Disney has always created the greatest
villains and what's scarier than a
middle-aged woman who's obsessed with
housework virtually anything this is
best villain
you
this one is rough because it really is
like comparing apples to oranges well to
Snow White that's an easy choice
the original is said by many to be one
of the greatest Disney Villains ever
with her style Grace and love of all the
villainous things that she does the only
downside is it's only explained in
narration why she doesn't like
Cinderella because of this it's a little
harder to identify with her motivation
in the new film we see how her
bitterness is born she hears her husband
confessed that he preferred the first
wife more which makes her angry towards
his offspring all the more
understandable we also see her slowly
Laura Cinderella into the role of
servant showing how patient and
manipulative she can be the downside to
that is it may make her too human by
comparison which one is more frightening
the one whose motivations are made
totally clear or the one shrouded in
mystery you're supposed to have no
sorrow for the original is so slimy and
hateful there's virtually no good in her
at all well the new one is so fragile
relatable that you can see the tragedy
play out in every mean-spirited move
that she makes the original acts like
someone who's in control while the
remake acts like someone who wants to be
in control I guess it's kind of like
comparing Zuko with Frollo boy one of
them needs a breakfast cereal one is
sympathetic while the other is pure evil
both still coming off as complex and
interesting so how do we really judge
which one is best
well I guess whichever one scares us the
most is the most intimidating well I
guess that speech that the new one made
in the dark is creepy in its own right
Wow ah but the new one has the mind of a
sociopath which is very psychologically
terrifying but the new one has a more
developed past allowing her to okay she
wins God that look is scary
some people just can't handle a good
old-fashioned death glare dad you whore
remember I can point just as hard as you
yeah we seem to have unbelievable power
with this don't we
Wow never forget
hey hyper fine a chance are you of
Indian descent no why
Oh
as 20 metal plates in my head though I
downside is I don't know what half the
were subpoenaed ask me ask me the
definition of Seagal what's the
definition of Seagal stop my god boy
honey you don't get it when you hire an
assassin you use only him for life no
you don't understand
when you have a review already full of a
ton of estrogen hey and the delicate
happened that estrogen is threatened you
weak in a demon that will not sleep into
the night oh by the way honey I got your
hat thank you no problem babe into the
night you might be good with a gun but
you're nothing compared to my stealth ha
I can see you coming a mile away I was
looking right at it how did he do that
is something wrong possum beer nothing
hard either you and your lady friend
keep talking princesses not calling me
that I have to bury my bullets in the
bloody body of a bastard like that no no
this one has more bullets I love your
skull crusher I love you turtle duck ah
back to the debate but that all sounded
amazing pretty okay fine this is that
side character
though everyone remembers the talking
mice in the original they're very
scaled-down in the remake to the point
where they don't even speak a different
tone to say the least but everybody
loves the singing mice and they're
slightly sexist lines
hey Stallone did it a sweater but come
on who can forget Lucifer the cat or the
whores or the dog the King and servants
the stepsisters these are characters we
all remember yes you remember them
because there's a ton of time devoted to
them too much time in the remake the
supporting cast days exactly that
supportive in the original they hijack
the movie on several occasions while
they're cute and all they take time away
from the more important elements like
the prints and the chemistry that's
supposed to build between him and
Cinderella but hey you were talking
about how the King gets way too much
time in the old one he gets just as much
time in the new one
yes but it's with the prince every scene
with him is helping develop the princess
character even more establishing his
responsibilities his goals and his
connection with his father we never even
see the prince and his father together
in the original apart from an eye-roll
but again it was a very passionate
eyeball
I suppose the last big one to talk about
the fairy godmother in the new one she's
played more for less because well she
selling a bottom Carter and that's what
you do with her now
but you have to admit some comedy is
very welcomed after Cinderella's at her
lowest moment and also she has to prove
her worth by disguising herself as a
homeless lady looking for water and it's
only after Cinderella gives it to her
that she grants all her wishes
but isn't that kind of pointless she has
to know she's a kind person if she's
showing up there I mean watching her
like a godmother
maybe but have you figured this
Cinderella is in shambles she can't go
to the ball her dress is ruined and her
family hates her most people in that
state would be too frustrated to be nice
to the old woman so by helping someone
else even in one of her worst moments
its immense what a good person she is I
guess but I don't know the other one
talks to her like a loving grandparent
someone she's familiar with enough to
know she would do that anyway she has a
warmth and a comfort that needs to be
seen after such hardship I wouldn't want
to laugh after going through all this
how would I feel supported and after
years of slaving for your family
suddenly being put to a test to see if
you're a nice person does not seem very
supportive okay maybe the fairy
godmother is a little better in the
original dimension she's a liar too
and you find that really comfortable I
got glass sneakers because of her they
are but the fact still remains that the
supporting cast does more than support
they take over they steal scenes that
shouldn't have to be stolen by them
while there is still focus on Cinderella
and the stepmother other important
elements are being overlooked and the
new film keeps the focus where it should
be the main characters stay the main
characters and the supporting roles stay
the supporting roles I guess I can't
really fault you on that new gets the
point you forgot a heartless prince joke
shut up
but as simple as a story is there's
always room to muck it up trust me
Disney's done it before this is which
one mucked it up less
the fine thing about a simple story is
they can be surprisingly tough to tell
you want to connect with the characters
in a relatable setup but even in an hour
and a half you have to know what to
expand on and what to keep linden like
said before the first film expands too
much on the side characters and not
enough on some of the main ones but in
the new films case the attempts to add
more detail can help some scenes but
seriously damage others for example when
Cinderella is not allowed to say at the
table with the others it's when she
realizes she's truly not a part of the
family causing her to finally break down
this is a powerful scene and all but it
then ruins the moment when her dress is
destroyed or slightly ripped oh yeah
that's that's a gut-wrenching moment but
even if they did like the original it
wouldn't work because we got the
breakdown earlier because of this the
arrival the fairy godmother is not as
powerful in the anime one it's by far
her lowest moment because they knew to
save it
thus you feel more emotion for her and
even more relief when the fairy
godmother arrives but the story does
allow for other emotional moments that
weren't in the first the King for
example is given a lot of time with his
son and when he passes away it's a
legitimately sad moment the ways they
allow Cinderella and the prince to meet
before the ball are also very clever
giving them more time to form a
connection the problem with that is
every single time she leaves the house
it makes for a slightly less magical
night when she goes to the ball
Cinderella goes to the town and quite a
few other places several times in the
new one which is fine but in the
original everything she does is in that
one location it's a nice location so
it's not visually dull but that's all
you ever see the story is very clever
and keeping her there as not only does
it emphasize the feeling of being
imprisoned but also the freedom when she
does leave and enters this heavenly
dreamlike castle therefore we're more
sucked into the experience because like
her it's our first time seeing it yeah
but all the wasted time with the side
characters yeah but all the time waste
on the unneeded exposition but
everything in the original is so obvious
and this one isn't gee I wonder what the
message was again huh courage
I have courage and be kind have courage
and be kind have courage and be kind be
kind and have courage fine I guess
there's both good things and bad things
about them yeah I guess it just depends
if you're looking for a more mystery or
more explanation so what do we do in
this case can there be a tie a tie
that's for pussies who don't believe
some animals more equal than others
there's pros and cons to both I don't
think we're gonna find one that's better
than the other okay I guess we can have
a tie I'm not gonna let this choice to
mean my masculinity nor anything else in
the rest of this video
all right buddy you want to play dirty
well time to play with Johnson justice
Oh
mother God knows we talk about pretty
much everything you can talk about but
there is one less element to discuss the
most important element of the movie the
main character this is the best sindorim
now this one you know you have to give
to the remake it's like everyone says
this Cinderella is stronger more
independent more intelligent and more
developed than that simple songbird who
does practically nothing in the first
film the audience's liked heard the
critics liked ER coma
this is hands down the winner well I
would agree with you if it wasn't for
one solitary fact what's that you're all
full of shit
what makes this Cinderella independent
well she leaves the house goes into town
and has smart conversations with the
prince hmm so she could leave the house
at any time why does she stay there and
take all bad abuse well like she says
it's her father's home because I made my
mother and father a promise to cherish
the place we were so happy always that
why she ends up leaving at the end
anyway and even but was her father's
home why go through all that hardship
just for that well okay it doesn't quite
make sense but the one in the other film
could leave - not really you see in the
original the father died when she was
just a child
this gives the stepmother plenty of time
to brainwash her and make her things
she's supposed to feel guilty and serve
her family and seeing how she was kept
in the home all that time this indicates
she doesn't know much about how the real
world works she talks to rats and bird
for crying out loud
in the new one the father dies when
she's an adult she leaves all the time
in fact her friends yeah she has friends
in this one say she should leave that
place why do you stay there when they
treat they loved our house and now that
they've gone I love it for them so this
makes absolutely no sense by attempting
to make her quote smarter and
independent they actually opened up a
ton of Platteville's making her look
dumber and weaker okay so she's not the
brightest wand in Hogwarts but you have
to admit she's stronger she's not as
passive as the animated one really in
the original she felt stuck in her
position but she clearly didn't like it
she did get angry she did have her
breaking points even though she was
taught over the years to be a certain
way she was still human and relatable
this one aside from her one big
breakdown which they tried to do twice
just kind of smiles and looks happy like
a zombie most of the time in fact in the
anime one when it comes to being locked
in the Attic tanned held against her
will she does try to get out she hits
the door she screams she has her animal
friends for help she does everything she
can to get out of there in the new one
she fully accepts her doom and just
spins around in circles humming to
herself yeah this is the strong
independent role model the critics were
talking about
she actually escapes by mistake when the
animals open up the window and they hear
her voice that's not strong that's the
definition of giving up while also being
saved by luck but uh she's so charming
no she's not allowed to be because
they're focusing more on her being smart
and independent people miss what makes a
strong character is how they deal with
their flaws their fears their turmoils
their troubles that get in the way
that's what makes them relatable but
this cinderella doesn't have any flaws
at least none that they'll acknowledge
you could argue she's too passive but
what does she do to solve that
let someone else save the day and not
even try this Cinderella at least gave a
shit because while having a character be
strong is good it's more important to
have them interesting first this
character is not interesting I'm not
gonna act like the original is the best
written character but you felt her pain
you understood her anger and you cheered
for her when things went right because
she allowed you to see her most fragile
moments but and that's why you're
falling for it it looks the part and
sounds the part but it's not portraying
the part it's like the to charli's from
the Willy Wonka movies one is an
emotional yet dreamful kid and the other
is Jesus we're obviously going to relate
to the one that acts more like a real
kid because we all were real kids we can
relate to that it's the same thing here
it doesn't matter what you claim she is
or isn't if you don't connect with her
there's no emotion and this movie has
made it impossible to connect with her
because they tried to make her flawless
ironically creating unintentional flaws
with her that are
never acknowledged or resolved but
psychos - the old sparkly
so everything wrapped up let's see who
the winner is another time what the hell
man we tan tan like this yeah we need to
find the best Cinderella movie yeah
didn't expect old Johnson justice didja
now open your mouth I'm gonna give you
the finishing blow
honey raisin can you help us settle a
dispute ah this doing a little book club
going on I swear to god you're trying to
decide what's the better Cinderella film
the original or the remake really you're
asking me this right now answer the
question
cartoon a remake yeah the cartoon of the
remake ever after the two Barrymore
movie yeah
I mean there's nothing wrong with it's
cool it's smart it's got sword fighting
Morticia Addams as the stepmother hell
even Cinderella does a little fighting
yeah there's no magic but I hate that
shit I got Johnson justice now if you'll
excuse me I'm gonna finish what I start
damn it how does he keep doing that
Benny what's your favorite cinderella
movie Oh ever after what the writing is
clever the characters are interesting
the villain is fun and there's just
enough changes to keep it fresh but
still stay true to the heart of the
story actually the more think about it
it is a really good cinderella story
yeah like really good Cinderella is
strong but interesting the villain is
evil but also intriguing there's plenty
of action and adventure but good romance
and dress porn we should just pick that
one are we allowed yeah why not I mean I
think everybody can agree the two
Cinderella movies have pros and cons and
everyone's just gonna kinda like the
version they like but never after is
clearly better yeah let's do it let's
give it two ever after you got it the
best cinderella movie is ever after
because it's my show and I could do
whatever the goddamn hell I want
well no certainly an interesting
discussion and with a twist ending yeah
but what do we do now
I don't know it seems a little weird to
kill a fellow ever after fan there's
only one incredibly manly thing to do in
this situation
Siri play ever after
once again the magic of Angelica Houston
unites us all now this is how real men
spend their Friday night
oh don't worry about Saul you're not
alright do tonight Thanks
so was she drunk during this movie too
I'm not entirely sure I'm just glad she
actually does something
her dress isn't as good but it's still
pretty badass isn't it usually the other
way around like you start off sober and
then you get drunk as you get older I'm
always drunk
it's never too girly where is Angelica
you're sena like i know she's right in
front of you don't get me wrong i mean
like just the actress where'd she go
Jamaica I think oh she might not be
there anymore
oh how wondering what a old white woman
was doing there babe
alright okay it's not like there we
gonna do Adam's family free
next week we take a look and see is
there still really whitewashing but you
can see it now under vessels ad-free
early access just three dollars a month
to see tons of people's videos early as
well as a bunch of other extra features
check it out and get the early scoop hey
Doug Walker here doing the charity shout
out today we are doing big cat rescue
big cat rescues mission is to provide
the best home they can for cats in their
care as well as end the abuse of big
cats in captivity and prevent their
extinction they have made species of
cats many of whom are threatened
endangered or extinct now in the wild
these cats are here for a variety of
reasons including abandoned by owners
wrongfully thought they would make good
pets abused by owners in order to force
them to perform save from being
slaughtered to make fur coats or even
just rescued as babies after hunters
killed their mothers with your help you
can see these animals live the proud
lives that they deserve go to their
website or especially check out their
YouTube channel to see all the
incredible videos of how amazing
beautiful and just downright cute these
creatures are come on how can you say no
to these guys go to their site and check
them out in all their cuteness today